[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno seguro que todos habéis escuchado
muchísimas canciones de amor
seguro que las habéis bailado seguro que
las habéis cantado incluso pero sabemos
realmente que es el amor
a mí me quedan dudas porque ni yo sé lo
que es amor a veces no
yo creo que el amor es
una gasolina que acciona un motor que
acciona el movimiento creo que el amor
es movimiento
esta acción es hacer y siempre estamos
con que el amor es sentir si es sentir
pero es es hacerlo
porque no hacemos porque siempre nos
quedamos como un poco paralizados y
dejamos que todo vaya porque no hacemos
porque tenemos miedo
mucho miedo
el amor cuando se funde con el miedo
genera un montón de
malas cosas como son los celos como son
mientras en cólera o días los respetas
quieres dominar el ego
el aliado del miedo es el amor tóxico
miedo
es el que es un aliado del amor tóxico y
por eso estoy aquí para hablar del amor
tóxico
el miedo te incapacita experimentar te
incapacita a salir de tu zona de confort
salir de
de tu clímax donde estás cómodo con la
otra persona y todo va bien no tienes
que salir tienes que
frank arte en el barro tienes que
realmente hacer cosas que nunca has
hecho porque no nos hacemos aprendiendo
y sin esas experiencias de
autoconocimiento de conocerse a uno
mismo sin esas experiencias no podemos
avanzar y tampoco podemos ser libres
porque la única la única libertad es
conocerse a uno mismo
yo fui ella ella una chica que acepto
todo que fue sumisa que dijo que sí
cuando había que decir que no que
prefería estar en una situación donde no
encajaba por simplemente que los demás
me viesen bien que los demás le aceptase
aunque yo no era así
y por todo eso
pues decidí no ser ella y empezar a
hacer yo
otra cosa
ayudado
para que borrar
a ver
ayuda
yo toda mi salas para que volara para la
legista ella porque ella ya está
problema ella porque ya que ella no será
la más lista pero la primera en la lista
ya que habla rato que no rechista ella
se conforma y está atrás
porque ya que ella pero la legista ella
[Música]
esta lista
yo fui a ella en un momento como os he
dicho y por ser ella no me di cuenta de
donde estaba metida por otorgar por todo
decirlo que sí por por ser quien no era
hasta que en vez de hacer yo y especial
darme cuenta de que estaba en una
relación tóxica y cuando empecé a darme
cuenta de que era yo empecé a decir que
no a las cosas y esas cosas hicieron en
la otra persona
que
y perder el interés por mí me engañaron
me abandonaron
y yo no entendía qué pasaba y lo que
pasaba era que era yo que estaba
haciendo yo por primera vez no
así que para salir de la toxicidad yo
creo que lo más básico es entender
fácil o más difícil que hay que ser uno
mismo
primordial luego creo
también dividamos mucho el amor no
siempre creemos que va a venir cupido
con una lámpara va a ser perfecto y va a
ser mágico
y que además es pasivo que puede ser
pasivo que nadie va a hacer nada por
nosotros que todo va a estar que
nosotros no tenemos que hacer nada que
el universo va a conspirar en hacernos
pues ponernos a nuestro servicio lo que
queramos y simplemente aunque te enfades
o lo que sea pues vas a decir pero es
que yo te quiero sí pero yo te quiero
pero no estás haciendo nada solo estás
así pero yo siento por ti sí pero no
estás haciendo nada sí pero qué
entonces
no basta con sentir hay que practicar
hay que hacer hay que accionar
la pareja ideal se nos ha vendido
siempre qué
que ha venido a complementarnos
nosotros tenemos que estar
complementados nosotros tenemos que ser
nosotros mismos la magia no existe el
amor mágico no existe además detrás de
la magia hay muchos trucos
yo no quiero eso el único truco que yo
veo aquí
es realmente la acción ese es el único
truco que hay para el amor además
también empezamos a tener expectativas
del otro a generar un montón de
expectativas que nos hacen realmente
sentir
un montón de insatisfacciones constantes
es todo un bucle es todo un bucle es un
bucle es un bucle y te quedas ahí y
tienes un montón de relaciones así
porque yo las he tenido y menos mal que
tengo la música para para que sea mi
terapia para que me ayudaron estancarme
ahí
yo creo que hay que construir lo que
tenemos esta responsabilidad cuando
estamos en una relación
liderar el amor lidera tu propio amor
lidera te a ti primero y luego lidera el
amor con la otra persona
hay que romper estereotipos hay que
romper condicionamientos
hay que dejar de idealizar el amor
porque el amor no se compra
con cenas no se compra con dinero no se
compra con joyas
no se compra con mentiras ni tampoco se
vende
ni tampoco se compra con flores de
colores
y
yo más quiero conocerte pero sin
intenciones de aprovechar que mis
valores amigos
pues nadie me ve bien
[Música]
no
y ya está
cascadas comida me hechos no valen
palabras yo yo no quiero flores que sean
de color
por ello no quiero a nadie que el mes
menciones
yo no quiero besos sino distintos versos
yo no quiero nada más
[Música]
quiero la verdad
bueno el amor no se compra como he dicho
hay que construirlo y como creéis que se
construye
a mí para comprender lo que es el amor
no tóxico sea el amor sano creo que hay
una premisa de tres siglas
el cr l confianza respeto libertad eso
si podeis tatuar oslo aquí en la mente
en el corazón en vuestro ser porque eso
nos va a ayudar un montón
hay que ser libre hay que tener un amor
libre el otro que te acompañe en un
viaje que haga sacar la mejor versión de
ti mismo que el otro te ayude a hacer la
mejor
brisa en este caso que puedo ser la
mejor laura la mejor marca el mejor
carlos
la mejor persona
la autoconciencia es súper importante y
por eso con la otra persona lo puedes
llevar sabes pues crear un camino en el
que la autoconsciencia tanto propia como
la del otro pues puedan concluir y que
sea un espejo además que sea un espejo
que te muestre todo lo feo de ti que no
te gusta y que tú tengas la
determinación y la seguridad en ti mismo
para no tener mecanismos de defensa en
contra del otro y ser amable con esa
persona y abrazar las críticas y abrazar
esa esa construcción ese espejo que el
otro hace de ti no
acompañado mucho mejor yo creo que sí la
puedes encontrar y la encuentra mucho
mejor pero que si no solo también se
está muy bien
yo siempre digo que uno más uno no es
igual a dos es igual a tres siempre lo
digo la gente se me queda por qué pues
porque al final tú eres uno la otra
persona es otro y juntos
su maíz
la individual habilidad de uno más la
individualidad del otro más vuestra
propia individualidad que construir
juntos que cuidéis que que abraza jce
que complementa jce que
apoyáis y que no dejáis que nada
es a esas condiciones que habéis hablado
entre vosotros no se rompan porque
entonces el juego es hipócrita en falso
no es lo que siempre pasa que por detrás
se hacen cosas y no nos es libre para
contarse las al otro por miedo de que el
otro siempre el miedo siempre el miedo
siempre el miedo yo tengo un mantra que
siempre me digo cuando lo paso como lo
he pasado tan mal 6 cuando quiero
conocer a alguien digo bien a brisa el
mantra el mantra del mando y el mantra
es que nadie me va a salvar nadie va a
ser un salvavidas para mí nadie me va
hacer algo que yo no pueda hacer por mí
nadie va a amarme si yo no me llamó
nadie va a respetarme si yo no me
respeto yo te siempre pues no sé por ser
guapa por ser modelo por por un montón
de clichés que se imponen no por ser
mujer también por ser joven siempre se
te tiran encima y tú les da el brazo y
si te cogen hasta el cuello y al final
no acaba siendo tú
y yo pues ha sido muy difícil para mí
porque yo no me respetaba a mí misma
entonces veía como nadie me respetaba
yo no me amaba a mí misma entonces nadie
me amaba y las personas que tenía al
lado solo eran vampiros emocionales no
qué bien que me di cuenta de que bien
así que yo lo que me digo para no volver
a caer en este tipo de relaciones es
muéstrate
al otro muestra tus heridas muéstrate
como eres no tenga filtros se permeable
qué pasa que te van a engañar pues es
una lección aprendes no hay errores aquí
además de en el amor no sé no hay egos
no hay culpables no hay competición
solo es cooperación solo es amar desde
la libertad
[Música]
yo soy
y
[Música]
estoy lista para mí
como quiero ir
[Música]
hoy mejor
sin aditivos sin condimentos sin
mentiras sin arrepentimientos sin darlo
todo para después perderlo sin equipaje
para ir más ligeros sin condiciones
temprano en mis progresos modificados
contra todo esto no estamos personas de
carne y hueso con muchas virtudes y
pocos defectos
que resultan de trans por un monto hay
que demoler lo que mejoraré de quién es
futuro
tú que vas as the baby
[Música]
como quiero
bueno salir
en la relación salir de una relación
tóxica es muy positivo es muy muy
positivo porque salir de ella
fortalecido
es el mejor aprendizaje que nos podemos
llevar desde mi óptica desde mi
experiencia todo lo que he hecho
malo lo he echado como lo he echado pues
a través de mi arte a través de mis
canciones a través de mi música música
que transforma música que dice algo a
los jóvenes que no solo te hace bailar y
pasar el rato un entretenimiento un
mainstream pero con contenido un
entretenimiento pero con contenido creo
que es muy importante donar nuestro
talento y que cada uno de los que
estamos aquí lo tenemos con lo que
hagamos sea con
la física la química
la medicina
o sea con la música o sea con lo que sea
así que yo hizo una canción que se llama
lo malo que ha servido de himno
feminista en él
en este año en este 2018 el 8 de marzo y
toda la hilera de mujeres lo han llevado
en sus pancartas así que
lo malo para todos vosotros para el
mundo para las jóvenes
[Aplausos]
[Música]
de otros te voy a acordar ya no hay
vuelta atrás me llama no respondo tira
porque éste no estatizar ver que aquí ya
es la perla y sigo porque en verdad a mí
a otra sólo comparte llegarme pero si me
pongo no la tocó
yo he sido el cuándo el dónde y con
quién que voy a dar de mí y otra y otra
vez todo lo que yo te dije en mente
cuando fue y voy a parar porque tú
[Música]
no es mi vida mal ahora
yo no estás dentro de mí se han podrido
las pones aquí y ahora ya no quiero
rosas
[Música]
sigo porque te toca a ti pero se perdió
el tiro porque una y otra vez no lo
comparte
pero si me toca toca toca dar yo decido
cuándo lo tengo claro que voy a hacerte
a mí y otra y otra vez todo lo que yo te
dije voy a bailar por qué
[Música]
no
no fuera lo malo no no no yo no quiero
nada malo
no no
yo no te mira y tú me vas a ver yo no te
escucho y tú me vas a ir pasó de largo y
paso de ti esta noche baila mejor sin ti
yo no me animaba a saber yo no te
escucho y tú me vas a oír pasó de largo
y voy a por mí esta noche baila mejor
sin ti era un chico malo no había robado
no todo yo no quiero nada malo no no no
en mi vida un palo palo palo en tigo
mano no todos fueran humanos
porque va mala o mala
[Música]
a mayor
[Aplausos]
[Música]